so we ended up building was basically a
petri dish except that it's 2 feet by 4
feet and the way we set it up is that
there are 9 bands and at the base of
each of these bands we put a normal
petri dish thick agar with different
amounts of antibiotic on the outside
there's no antibiotic just in from that
there's barely more than this Nicole I
can survive inside of that there's ten
times as much 100 times and then finally
the middle band has a thousand times as
much antibiotic and then across the top
of it pour some thin agar that bacteria
can move around in the background is
black because they're thinking it and
the bacteria appear as white first you
see they spread in the area where
there's no antibiotic up until the point
they can no longer survive then a mutant
appears on the right it's resistant to
the antibiotic it spreads until it
starts to compete with other mutants
around it when these mutants hit the
next boundary they to have to pause and
develop new mutations to make it into
ten times as much antibiotic
and you see the different mutants repeat
this at 100
and after about 11 days they finally
make it into 1,000 times as much
antibiotic as the wild-type can survive
and so we can see by this process of
accumulating successive mutations that
bacteria which are normally sensitive to
an antibiotic can evolve resistance to
extremely high concentrations in a short
period of time